a criar o clima que se levantassem todos
pensávamos 12 chá e depois passados não
temos pessoas não falam português e
tanques abriram cedo terminar eu sabia
da usp protecção jazz fio aos pixl a
sepromi se não estiver à altura do
evento mas eu passei noites em apa e
jorge palma acordar e madeira todo
também não sei por que escrever humor há
13 anos e alma não poucas vezes a miúda
vem esta idéia de perguntar para que
serve um humor muito vocês irão dizer
ontem serve pra vir aqui é pra rir quem
por que vocês podem pensar que muito do
seu exemplo uma criança e 300 vezes por
um adulto e 17 em média não é quando as
pessoas aqui gostam do rio um jovem da
usb além dos insultos bem à vontade não
surpreende que até uma caixa e vocês
sabem disso
o astute macacos antropóides 50 e
gorilas orangotangos rim e as atitudes
que dizem que ratos jovens mt
vocalizações ultrassônicas quando brinca
se cães adianta aliás voltarmos atrás
começaram do zero proprietário e
campinas nos desenvolvimentos
expressivos da comunicação não verbal
foi o primeiro a escrever precisamente
com o sorriso eo riso são movimentos
possíveis cenários e universais e
trechos acima de tudo cuidar e ele
falava em todas a imagem é que talvez o
painel assim o antónio irá falar disto
do tanto rir enquanto ato biológico
porque quando se rir a libertação de
energia tanto riso uma expansão de
energia nervosa uma transição rápida
entre um pensamento e outro faz com essa
reserva indígena voz da seita gasta
movimento informa informado isso é isto
sim será do tamanho do painel não sair
como vocês sabem o corpo de gregg é esta
central filhos né há semanas que cativam
quando quando sentimos o prazer
tantativa da produção dos componentes e
bioquímicos como combiná
neurotransmissores melhor o anime e
adrenalina é o tanto eu passo isso
talvez o risco é involuntário
biológica às vezes pensando fisiológico
e às vezes até pergunta fisiológico não
no sentido do daguestão pensar mais
difícil filosofia muitas vezes meus
alunos
eu dou aulas e às vezes de humor
dezembro
moro filosofia e explicações tanto o
frei do manual ken thomas hobbes aonde
anda bem no o rb que são todos eles diz
caron humor há há há muitos muitos anos
atrás
várias teorias do humor a três delas uma
quarta que o filho teria o livro se
cuidar da incoerência uma alma quarta
que o com o aspecto central do humor é a
violência tanto uma mistura de atração e
e frustração mas nunca imagina daqui
portanto eu pensava mas talvez pela pela
teoria uma das mais conhecidas do 2º
troy estabelece para o lulismo salvio
entrou sexo essa essa libertação de
entre o sexo e humor
fred está na teoria do livro humor a
barquense dois índices básicos do ser
humano a sexualidade ea ccee virada ea
teoria do livro diz precisamente isso
como uma opção nas exigências sociais
convencionais pode ser encarado como um
fornecedor de lívio e destruição que se
impõe ao vivo em que impõe essas
exigências sociais tanto pessoas passam
por tensões podem dar gargalhadas
de repente a atenção for removida às
vezes acreditamos agir visto
estamos aqui desde que houvesse a
libertação ea pessoa já cento e vai vai
vai rir o movimento atinge do livro
suponho que tanto que esse elemento
central humor seja o sentimento de
alívio provocado obviamente pela remoção
dessas dessas barreiras tanto o fred
também o humor como como uma uma o
nojento tapas por isso como 111 em bata
a censura por exemplo um insulto a ser
engraçados inicialmente para ser um
elogio eu posso chegar aqui o portal
vermelho estamos aqui no bastião do
pinto da costa e pós querer brincar com
o pinto da costa e outro a dizer à avó
pinto da costa é o senhor espetacular
lugar numa mulher da vida e transformar
o escritório em dois dias pra mim é
nível
eu estou basicamente aquilo que nós na
língua portuguesa dos inimigos por para
o lips y é mais que o falar sem falar a
pessoa quer falar de algo mas não fala
desse posse a 15 para o inter
nós já falamos do sporting
eu quero atacar o sporting mas tô a
direcionar por outro lado eu posso dizer
lá a chupeta claro tony carreira juntar
20 mil mulheres no pavilhão atlântico e
eu próprio fui lá ver estava admirado em
jokela as suas faces gordas ficar com
elas é que para ele portanto eu estou lá
no fundo eu quero outra cara à espanha
estônia reino de deus todos salvar
sempre o universo da autora a carreira
junta muita gente estão a pensar que
estou a falar isso porque nos rimos
voltamos a a mesma a mesma questão
sempre seguimos do nada
uma das teorias de do filósofo
principalmente o emanuel tente discursos
na transformação repentina dessa grande
expectativa para o nada eo que quero
nada é a surpresa nós nós queremos
principalmente não haverá uma piada para
mim uma piada uma equação não é tanto o
risco de servir e em dois estágios não é
que o senhor vai pro search monkey
médicos poderão dizer que no novo aqui
central é é que que são o be esta piada
é esta equação é feita de maneira a
primeira piada que vai ligar um final em
40 causará essa essa surpresa obviamente
tanta emoção é no fundo o desafio é com
casamentos para as funcionárias problema
do sul no fundo do cérebro é desafiada
em tributar uma incongruência de forma
entender uma piada
o que nós temos aqui tanto o piadas em
do lado cômico ao vivo em qualquer
situação um rumor do whorkshop a obra
depende obviamente do prazer de
encontrar conexões privadas em estradas
entre essas duas idéias e essas idéias
pra mim é uma piada trás em muito mais
força enquanto tiver dado de surpresa
na verdade surge numa ação em que eu
posso dizer que realmente cruza com o
que vocês não acreditaram na semana
passada estive no brasil porque não ser
a verdade isso não é uma credibilidade
que o desvio para saber que numa
explosão em copacabana
você vai querer ver o padre frederico
gil portugal seguidos a prova realiza-se
de prova também é credível
qual é a surpresa estava pedindo um
garoto
é que essa conexão entre os dois pontos
que o cérebro é desafiado a fazer e
extra natal ao parto também convidada
pra da piada dependerá sempre do grau de
contraste entre esses dois elementos e
ea sua fusão
temos isto o que quis nos cinemas 2 pelo
menos 500 acção o setap anthony appiah
lá no fundo resume estas duas coisas nós
temos etapa enquanto preparação da piada
tanto circo vão situar o interlocutor no
espaço-tempo ração ea quando foi
precisamente nessa surpresa e conclusão
da piada
o que estamos um exemplo prático ok ele
apresenta semana passada fez uma
tentativa sem vítimas
bin laden já disse que não não acertaram
tanto ele como não acertaram neste caso
temos um setup estudos a situar que eu
vou tentar no vítimas bin laden não está
a par da credibilidade lado vai fazer um
comentário tão toque defesa tentassem
vítimas bin laden já diz como não
aceitaram passar na agecopa que será
então a conclusão dessa piada talibãs o
ano em que o humor às vezes às vezes tem
o tamanho alta principalmente colegas
quando são iniciados epa não consigo
fazer uma piada e os negros para faz
forma matemática que de forma matemática
é basicamente somar as equações todas
impossíveis nós pegamos nessa no que foi
a pouco sendo o humor uma ea piada uma
equação matemática
nós chegamos e vamos chamar as coisas
vamos pegar em alguma coisa que não
falar
já estamos no por consolar ricardo
quaresma jogador do porto e o que
ricardo quaresma pode olhar o que tem
ricardo quaresma como é que eu posso
fazer uma piada com ela eu não estava a
jogar neste momento tanto se no porto ou
internação pouco jogou no chelsea de
ricardo quaresma este é o nosso 60
tanto ricardo quaresma não joga tanto
nós se vocês não se importarem fazemos a
piada todos em conjunto todos juntos é
que o colégio não joga o que não joga
tradição joga o treinador está a
dispensar o ricardo quaresma não é o que
que eu não jogasse porque é um futebol
muito bem acertaram e o senhor do
produto ela quanto o espetacular do
powerpoint pelo visto futebol com que se
joga futebol
a bola vai rolar a bola joga com bolas
mais que
não precisa de outras pessoas para jogar
eu juntos fizemos um adversário que está
nós estamos a construir piada desse lado
ainda pelo lado direito
agora vamos arrancar turismo quem o
ricardo quaresma jogador e homem qual é
a maior característica do ricardo
quaresma que salta à vista o fato de eu
ser cigam rolamento aquela menina que
diz bonzão se esse ano obviamente nós
somos posterior equipe estávamos na
ferida enquanto o da incoerência tires
do morto a poucos o avaí é o chegamos ao
menos um estereótipo e atira de
coerência vai explicar está a questão do
exterior teve estereotipando questão dos
ciganos o que nós fazemos o verbo roubar
sempre social chegamos é que poderíamos
construir uma piada tanto eu não entendo
como é colégio não joga aqui estão meus
etapa a minha preocupação se o princípio
do futebol estavam nos roubaram uma das
nossas metas da nossa equação piada
vossas esperanças importa estar a dizer
ela o princípio do futebol é roubar cá
em baixo a bola ao adversário também
entendo na quaresma nos jogos princípios
do dos colegas para o adversário
cometendo outros pensaram um cigano e
teremos que forma eu já fiz em
olimpíadas felizmente não preciso dessa
equação mas já fiz enviadas a amigos
meus a explicar e está em mil soluções
possíveis dois deles e vamos fazer
outras coisas em vez de ele ficar com
ciganos ou ficar por outro lado qualquer
porque voltamos a mesma coisa obviamente
achamos piada a qualquer coisa eo achar
piada é um querem de frente o porquinho
do que vimos é que a turma da unidade
estranha eu acho que é este versos é que
grande é grande dificuldade de
entendimento do que é piada e dos
juristas por nós rimos às vezes até por
impulsos nas dos rios é outra questão é
completamente diferente
tanto o desenrolar do chaparral ainda
com humor tendo o prazer de encontrar
conexões em disparada entre essas idéias
e estas ideias surgem de forma a ver
vocês olham para isto
josé saramago tem muitos clientes não
tenho com deus não sei que é esta
conexão que o encontro entre duas idéias
um católico não irá encontrar com o
dólar está também com deus permite tem
piada premiou a presença de josé
saramago
acho que tinha riscado estar também com
deus numa altura das quase ter como eu
é aqui que nos leva a compra também um
sinal porque o meu comportamento no
final faça uma situação é completamente
diferente do modelo que vai encarar
aquilo de uma forma muito mas muito mais
forte no vale aquilo por outro lado caso
a mesma coisa com isso eu e por isto a
igreja católica lá está é mesmo que sou
possivelmente não achei piada ao
saramago vai dizer é baixo não tem piada
nenhuma pro models é cristo eu aprendi
isto é triste foi cristo crucificado mas
se isso não tem acontecido
a igreja católica tem um problema
logotipo
se olharmos isso
para isso após martins vereadora são cá
está
isto leva-nos uma questão de comunicação
porque eu entendo vocês entendem que
conseguem erguer desconstruir isso com
humor é acima de tudo uma regra de
construção e é sim uma turma ficou
encerrado por nós estamos aí estamos
aqui numa freqüência 97.3 mas nada ver
pessoas que estão no meo ou lares não eu
não acho que ela está com esta questão
em outra freqüência
voltamos a mesma questão esta freqüência
solos am
só nos leva é que nós vamos rir daquilo
que conhecemos tanta pergunta pouco do
que os livros porque achamos piada mas
fechamos nada porque conhecemos se
estiver olhar para isto mostrou mora em
freixo de espada à cinta que não tenho
motivo para sua terra vai olhar e vai
dizer o que é isto
deus falar pra vocês não estou dizendo
que o metiê e eu cheguei porque este
indivíduo fica triste quando não tem sal
eu ganhar comissão
estamos todos a falar da mesma coisa
tanto está aqui uma freqüência igual
todos nós entendemos isso não é possível
é um boneco que que não sei que dois é
um boneco trabalha oito horas ou
mensagens vão levantar dinheiro está
fora de serviço e de café já não
acontecer o pico nos açores levantado em
ariel a vai vai o dinheiro da caixa
multibanco só uma no pico e ela acha que
eu vou nava por outra ou na volta ele
volta e isso é que eu vou fazer eu faço
isso aconteceu desde que uma idéia a
a arriba tm se eu fosse um boneco no
multibanco de vocês em vez de ficar
triste o que quer e não tem sal toma
era assim que eu faria querido moura
vamos puxar isto trilhos e privacidade a
trilha sobre dado como o próprio nome
indica
obviamente dje os indianos por uma coisa
curiosa uma glória repentina que às
vezes me deixa triste ou seja eu disse
não querer ouvir embora acabou história
para um dígito fumaças tudo aqui e não
sei não queremos glória repentina no
sentido e no final vai dar ou autoestima
seja um resgate de acidentes em frente à
enfermidade ideias e de experiências
passadas por cada indivíduo que sorria
querida sobriedade é precisamente isso
sorri daquilo que ultrapassou conseguiu
passar e depois vai rir disso eu digo
isso por exemplo acho completamente
estúpido hoje em dia sensores luz em
casa bancas ou centenas e nem terminou
de milho tem que estar assim o
interruptor vai subir por passou por
essa situação e superou a e consegue
usar mas já aconteceu comigo não sei que
eu acho mais arriscado em illinois de
campo eo ataque da lazio
tá tudo não está acesa
e aqui então surge esta tiridá sempre
dado provimento a um prazer implícito no
humor está na sensação de impunidade só
pessoas ou situações fazer rir
aliás o o os clouds os um charro a
história da torta na cara do indivíduo
escorrega na banana tudo isso vem desta
dívida sobre dado que obviamente estamos
reunidos do outro está numa posição
inferior à nossa obviamente tudo isto
leva nos resta esta frase do alecsandro
bem disto humor envolve a degradação de
alguma coisa é verdade tanto acabamos
sempre por rir de algo e uma desgraça e
nesse caso está muito claro que tire a
última teoria da incoerência amplos
disco rígido em defesa da cidade contra
os entre psi se recusam a juntar se nos
games nós vemos um indivíduo que nunca
rosa othon e vamos seguir sua agenda do
astro quando quase ninguém se deu tanto
é que está esta esta esta incoerência
rios do congro em tudo o que nos ajuda a
ajustar nossa cidade a este estilo
francês henri bergson recusa a ideia de
que o humor seja direcionado ao código
social em geral mas a cada indivíduo em
particular lista surgem os estereótipos
que à época também falavam tanto por
isso é que surgem coisas como o gene é o
padre roma
eu e isso pois é é engraçado como é que
as coisas podem pelo bicho eu estiver
aqui certos troços tross todos vocês vão
entender o armador san andrés propaga-se
não sei como por exemplo é toda a gente
encontra uma nota sobre um padre diz o
senhor padre só pensa naquilo que é
melhor para chapada quando todos os
padres fossem viseu é uma coisa é uma
coisa estranha e isso vai se propagando
e vamos criando esses estereótipos tanto
o que o movimento traz à luz pra que
serve um rumor é é é grande conclusão é
que nós temos diz para rirmos de nós
próprios também nós rimos nós próprios
eu gosto de apreciar a é preciso
português principalmente em que nós
temos coisas fazemos e que somos
caricaturáveis eu gostei por exemplo
portuguesa por pão na torradeira
a abertura deste tamanho com uma fatia
assim você não sai legal a ficha que
miguel teria com uma faca estava em
choque e houve comigo e pataxó que o
amigo vai lá aposentada choque
o time provável oitava 0 e mais lentas e
agora prova eo prova
eu não consigo entender voltamos à
gargalhada que é uma glória repentina
nos faz sentir bem nós nós obviamente
nos faz sentir bem obviamente que isto
nos faz nos leva obviamente faz sentir
bem
nós rimos daquela da teoria da
incoerência eu gosto também de uma parte
com nosso envolvimento do alheio e rimos
da desgraça no sentido em que a eu tava
lá mal eu dei um erro por exemplo adoro
os portugueses que transformam o gasóleo
em gasol espetacular tipo ênfase do
combustível na refinaria passar a
gasolina ou gasóleo não é que é uma
coisa eu gosto e acima tudo a evolução
da língua que é uma coisa que não me vou
precisando hoje em dia porque a língua
vai ruim de antigamente por exemplo uma
doença é doente tem uma doença hoje em
dia tem uma patologia que fazer mais uma
criança que não aprendi essa escola era
burra hoje em dia têm dificuldades de
aprendizagem varejo num folheto
ministério da educação que falava em
crianças com inadaptação ao custo ao
conhecimento
no fundo é pacenas na mesma são
alérgicas para não é culpa da criança
não é culpa da criança que hoje em dia
diz que o crescimento de crianças em
praticamente uma criança fosse aplicada
na veia da imagem
hoje em dia é imperativo tal outra
criança hiperativa deixava tal outra vez
vai fazer o médico diz que é baratinho
também vai fazer quando voltamos em
risco de terminar o humor fácil sentir
bem obviamente faz os juristas vão
salvar o mundo
não não vão salvar o mundo os juristas
vão matar a fome
não vou matar a fome os nomes vão
funcionar as alterações climatéricas não
vão funcionar as alterações climatéricas
smith vão salvar e resolver crises não
vão e voltamos à primeira pergunta por
que quiser rumor de viseu para nada
obrigado